this is a place that has seen a lot of
human tragedy
you can bundle it up under the blanket
of a curse but you can't deny that there
is something at work here
some relationship between west virginian
industry
and a seemingly endless cycle of
calamity
and since austin caperton won't be
providing any answers
i'm turning to a trusted old buddy
science
so what we do in this lab is we build
stuff
and we break it to figure out how to
make it stronger what a cool job man
no disaster is woven into the local
folklore of west virginia
quite like the collapse of the silver
bridge i think
there's a reason behind it it just
didn't happen to happen
they said that the mothman appeared
before the bridge fell
it's like a legend although i'm fairly
certain the flying cryptid didn't cause
this disaster
the silver bridge did collapse at the
exact spot where the battle of point
pleasant was fought
and some say that was the cause of chief
cornstalk's dying curse
so what does science have to say about
that peculiar coincidence
this is a model of the silver bridge
cool
so the silver bridge was similar to a
suspension bridge
except that the suspension cables were
actually
eye bars so tell me exactly how the
silver bridge failed
what happened there was a fly it was
actually located at the end of the eye
bar that flaw was extremely small and
actually wasn't visible because it was
hidden under the
cap of the pin and in this case a very
small flaw
initiated a fracture can you show me
what that would look like
okay so we're going to apply a tension
load meaning we're going to pull on this
what's this kip what is that so a kip is
1 000 pounds so we're at 0.21
000 pounds or in other words 22 pounds
it's incrementally adding load
this no longer is contributing at all
all the force that was in this component
is now dumped into this one
right in the case of the silver bridge
this happens so fast the first one
failed and immediately
let's uh let's do it on our model okay
and here's where we smash stuff in the
name of science
so we're going to simulate the fracture
of the eye bar by
cutting one of the yellow strings
when one eye bar failed there just
wasn't enough capacity in the rest of
the system
to resist all of the weight of the
structure
and therefore the entire bridge
collapsed
so the silver bridge collapses what's
the
way this could have been prevented the
original designs
for this bridge called for a suspension
cable
but they decided to opt for a less
redundant system
with the ibar chains which allowed them
to dramatically reduce the cost
but it also dramatically reduced the
redundancy in the system
for those of you at home who never took
an interest in civil engineering
let me spell it out for you redundancy
equals
safety so if they hadn't done this with
the lowest bidder
there's a possibility that that failure
would have happened but they would have
had enough redundancy but the bridge
wouldn't have collapsed that's right
[Music]
you